Рекомендую всім як батько трошки більше
року дитини купувати українські
підгузники які суттєво дешевші але по
суті згоден 860
грн недостатньо для того щоб забезпечити
дитину необхідним цікаво що тут
прозвучала просто шикарна порада ви
знаєте фантастично Ми пам'ятаємо всі
поміняй собаку щоби сплатити комуналку
Ну це вже історичний мем правда це не
завадило людині зараз бути виконуючим
обов'язки голови комітету з питань
свободи слова Ну так тепер нова порада
купляйте дешевші памперси і це говорять
слуги народа які собі купили лексуси
Мерседеси Porsche за вже під час війни
То може ви собі купити дешевше Mercedes
може Lexus подешевше візьмете може
подешевше Porsche буде А що ви кажете що
людям треба купляти дешевші памперси